Speaker 1: I'm not going to spend the entire
show on the Fox News text message revelations.
But there is one more set of revelations
that I want to talk about with you.
Some of these newly revealed texts expose that Fox
News propagandist Maria BARTIROMO and former Trump
adviser Stephen Bannon are true believers. With
Tucker Carlson, we learned he was pretending he
hates Trump, doesn't like him at all, thinks he's
a moron, hates him passionately, looked forward
to when he could stop talking about Trump. Maria
BARTIROMO and Steve Bannon seem to be actual true
believers. This is completely insane. Steve Bannon
and Maria BARTIROMO reports. Media matters plotted
to discredit Biden and get BARTIROMO elected to
the Senate. Bannon texted 71 million voters will
never accept Biden. This process is to destroy his
presidency before it starts. If it even starts.
This is so insane. Okay, let's look at a couple of
the text messages. Maria. Text Steve Bannon. Oh,
my God. I'm so depressed. I can't take this.
Can you join me Thursday? Sorry about the delay.
Bannon writes back. Yes, we've got this. Maria
BARTIROMO says, I am watching the world move
forward and it's so upsetting, Steve. Maria is
upset that the world is moving forward with Joe
Biden. Is the president. Why? Well, because Joe
Biden won. Maria adds, I want to see massive fraud
exposed. Will he be able to turn this around? I
told my team we are not allowed to say president
elect at all, not in scripts or in banners
on air until this moves through the courts.
Bannon then responded, As Media Matters writes,
71 million voters will never accept Biden. This
process is to destroy his presidency before it
starts, if it even starts. And BARTIROMO replied,
But I'm scared and sad. And Bannon says, You are
our fighter. Enough with the sad. We need you.
We need. We want you to run against. Schumer. This
is your moment. Bannon then texted BARTIROMO what
he called the plan. Listen to this. Number one, we
either close on Trump's victory or de-legitimize
Biden to win both seats in Georgia. That didn't
happen. Three Win back the House in 2022. Okay,
that did happen. Four Elect you to the Senate.
Five If we don't close on Trump victory now, have
Trump declare for 2024 the day after taking back
the House and your win in November of 2022. Now,
of course, Maria BARTIROMO did not end up running
for Senate. Trump did end up announcing that he
was running. But instead of right after the 2022
midterms, it was right before the 2022 midterms.
They seem to be true believers. Now, I want to add
one caveat here. Steve Bannon may be pretending
for the benefit of Maria BARTIROMO. Okay. Steve
Bannon is devious and smart enough that even these
text messages to me leave open the possibility
that Bannon doesn't believe any of this crap,
but he recognizes that Maria BARTIROMO
does. And so he's playing it up to her.
I don't know. But there are definitely some true
believers out there. My question to you, what's
worse, the true believers who are completely
disconnected from reality, like Maria BARTIROMO or
the people that are just lying like Tucker
Carlson, Who knows? Trump didn't win. Who
doesn't like Trump? Who hates Trump passionately?
But they go on air and they pretend reality is
different. Which is worse. Let me know what you
think. Leave it in a comment and you can find all
of these clips and text messages on our Instagram
by searching Instagram for The David Pakman Show.